[Musique]
tout ça
un divorce une dépression des rixes ou a
fait naufrage
ici dans les bidonvilles d'auckland que
l'on retrouve partout sur le bord des
autoroutes sous les viaducs dans les
quartiers industriels
[Musique]
comme des milliers de chinois les
parents de derrick immigrés dans la
région de san francisco au détour de la
seconde guerre mondiale animé du rêve
américain
sans se douter qu'un jour leur fils leur
est plutôt du côté de son cauchemar
depuis 2010 est la population sans abri
a plus que doublé à houplines dans sept
villes de quatre cent trente mille
habitants considérés comme une banlieue
de san francisco on estime qu'il y
aurait au moins 5000 personnes sans
logis et que des milliers d'autres
vivent dans la misère
[Musique]
non stop depuis le début de la pandémie
c'est l'hécatombe to b si les loyers
sont si chères à auckland
c'est que le rêve américain existe bel
et bien
tout à côté il fait du jogging du
chopper du surf
il prend du bon temps sur la plage à bt
maison avec vue imprenable sur la mer
le rêve américain des nouvelles
technologies à bétous dans la région
savons charles maison ça vaut dans les
milieux ont certainement la maison
moyenne cote au dessus d'un point 5
millions on est dans le palo alto qui
indécence platek la californie beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent dans la tech
vivait si laurence du sou à 27 ans elle
travaille comme journaliste au mercury
news le journal de silicon valley son
affectation sont vite comme on dit dans
le métier les inégalités sociales
elle ne couvre que ça dans le problème
n'est pas tant une structure entre ceux
qui ont le plus ceux qui ont le moins
ceux qui ont le plus les milliardaires
la californie et à l'instant 66,6 en
fait 135 milliards
depuis j'ai vu la pandémie et de l'autre
côté on a un californien sur cinq qui a
demandé de chômage en 2018 pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du pays
les américains les plus riches ont aussi
payé moins d'impôts que les plus pauvres
le résultat d'une forme fiscales de
l'administration 30 et l'état de la
californie favorise aussi les plus
nantis l'est
la taxation des riches qui permet au
mark zuckerberg est il une masse de ce
monde de s'enrichir et d'avoir très très
grande valeur nette
en fait sans que cette valeur le soient
taxés du 10 km ou en équipe devrait tuer
elle ne pouvait pour
[Musique]
dans les faubourgs d'auckland joe qui
vit dans un parc de roulottes déglingué
trouve que cette injustice est tout
naturel
il est vrai des rivaux
[Musique]
dans son campement humides des rixes ou
ne peut lui s'empêcher de rêver d'une
amérique plus juste une californie où
une milliards engrangés par les géants
natek servirait à construire des
logements pour des gens comme lui le
sans abri n'a plus rien plus il a gardé
des aspirations et les candidats à la
mairie d'auch clean
une course qui aura lieu en 2022